The Walking Dead is back on our screens
after its midseason break and it seems
like the show's creators are trying to
take it in a brand new bloodier
direction after the apparent death of
Rick Grimes and a huge time jump in the
prior part of the season the mid-season
premiere explores more of the world
though our heroes have been left in
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the latest episode as well as the
direction that the show could be heading
in there will be heavy spoilers here so
if you don't want to know anything about
the episode and then I highly suggest
that you turn off now but for everyone
else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I watch it so you don't
have to in the last episode not only did
naughty boy negan managed to escape his
prison cell in a Ted Bundy tribute but
we also got introduced properly to a
brand new band of survivors known as the
whisperers these zombies with moves like
jagger managed to not only kill our Lord
and Savior Jesus Christ but they also
managed to scare the crap out of
everyone watching the latest episode
picks up with negan on the run after
Judith lets him go informing him that
the outside world is as bacon desert
childhood negan soon learns this and
sees that his previous camp is no more
after returning to it throughout the
episode he attempts to go back to
Alexandria but is shot by Judith who
warned him that she would do it if she
ever saw him again she is caught
sneaking back to his cell and we get
some nice hybrid father figure and
daughter moments that will probably
become the spine of the show down the
line since called Stefan the show a lot
of the emotional beats with his
character from the comics are slowly
starting to play out with Judith instead
and going forward they will probably
become a lot closer
she's negan's real chance for redemption
and if we can learn to forgive him
maybe we can learn to forgive
liam neeson no nevermind on their way
back to help up Michonne and Daryl
managed to take a Whisperer hostage and
unmask them this turns out to be Lydia
who is being paired up with Henry even
though in the comics she paired up with
Carl
Lydia is alphas daughter and is sort of
a bad egg but also a good one in many
ways in the comics it becomes the
group's mission to save her from the
whisperers and this makes the tension
rise exponentially from her we learn
that the whisperers are survivors that
wear the skin of the Dead like it's the
latest fashion and use this as
camouflage to blend in anyway onto the
big thing to take from this episode we
learn that Rosita is pregnant and that
it's actually sadik's child and not
Gabriel's Eugene overhears all of this
and isn't happy after confessing his
love to Rosita but let's be honest the
guy has the emotional range of a
buckingham palace guard so who cares the
episode ends with Luke and Holden out
looking for the search bar that went
missing and it's here that they come
across out there and are captured by the
whisperers in the comics alpha captures
members of Alexandria similar to what we
saw in this episode Luke actually isn't
alive in the comics at this point which
doesn't really bode well for his capture
here so going ahead I think he will be
killed and made an example of alpha is
also responsible for beheading Rosita in
the books and obviously this would be
big news if she does it here especially
with the character being pregnant but I
can't really see this being the case
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the episode and what you think will
happen going forward if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and make sure
you check out my breakdown of the lego
movie to the second part which will be
linked at the end this is a channel for
people who are never missing television
so if that's the kind of thing you like
you need to subscribe to definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care peace
[Music]